[Music]
all right hello everyone my name is Jeff
Smith I'm here from Facebook
AI research and I want to talk to you
today about PI torch 1.0 the focus of
this talk is gonna be on this unique
journey between the mode of research and
production and so one really helpful
thing for me and getting to know your
needs is an audience would be to take a
really short poll and so the poll is
pretty simple so first which of you
would identify with the persona of
someone who does research you otter
author machine learning models you train
things like that who here would say that
you it's sometimes like thinking the
mode of a researcher okay great
and so then who here would say that they
support production systems live products
with users that need to like not go down
and be efficient okay all right so that
seemed like we skewed a little bit more
towards the production end of things
which was kind of my expectation for
this conference in terms of my personal
background I've spent most of my time a
little bit more closely aligned with
production systems but often for about
the past 10 plus years working on this
specific problem how do we take research
into production within AI technology and
so that's we're going to talk about
today here's the scope of some of that
as you can see I want to get some
context on what we do with AI in
products at Facebook specifically and
then dive into PI torch as a unique
technology that sits underneath all of
them and talk about how it can be used
within challenges you might have when
building products here's a here's the
intro to some of the things we use AI
for so these are there's a broad range
of things you can use AI for at this
point in time so this is this is an
example of social recommendations
understanding what it is you're looking
for and asking your friends next we this
is my personal favorite this is the one
I probably used at the highest frequency
I used to live in in Hong Kong and I
have a good number of friends who post
things in Chinese on my Facebook feed
and I need a machine to translate that
for me because I can't read the Chinese
similarly you may not have seen this
feature in action depending on on your
personal background but accessibility is
an incredible application of AI
technology where you can render content
which would have been inaccessible to
people with different abilities
accessible using AI comprehension of the
content on the page or the or the screen
those are existing products being made
better with AI there's also all sorts of
stuff that you can do that you never
could have done before so these are
examples of things like BOTS and
assistants here so conversational
intelligent agents that allow you to
accomplish tasks here this is an example
of generated thumbnails so when users
upload videos what is the best frame
that we want to show when someone is
displaying a preview of this video are
doing that automatically at scale this
is this is an example of something this
actually renders an AR map and so these
are augmented reality is a very exciting
area in which Facebook is doing a lot of
research and interesting product stuff
in and you see that in places like the
the camera stack inside Instagram and in
Facebook as well as we're investing in
in VR hardware and so this is things
like oculus rift and so you need a lot
of ability to reason about things like a
camera model and a person's experience
of space as they move through it in a
virtual reality experience that's not
all some of the things that people don't
always think of as being powered by AI
that really really matter our integrity
concerns and so these are things that
make your experience as a user of the
platform a lot better and so this is
detecting and people are doing bad
behavior like share baiting to protect
and as well as other things like like
spam or inappropriate content we need to
be able to classify those things very
rapidly before they show up in someone's
newsfeed and then here's a really
powerful example of suicide prevention
and so this is a there are all sorts of
unique problems that can come out when
you are actually working on the
challenge of what people are interacting
with on a social level in their human
relationships and so having AI
technology that can rapidly I flag
issues and then begin to get people into
those situations can be really impactful
and then there's this picture of things
and so the way that some people think
about how do you build a system that
does this right is Facebook uses an
ad-supported model so in addition to all
the posts that you put up your friends
put up there's some amount of sponsored
content in here and so we as builders of
ära products really need to think about
how to use AI technologies like high
torch to be able to make good decisions
to say what is going to be the the best
value for you over the long term not
just what is the most efficient way to
serve a bunch of ads to make money and
so we've been able to make substantial
advances within our use of AI technology
to give you a better experience over the
long term and think about ways to model
that in ways that are far more
sophisticated then will you click on
this at so the field of AI is advancing
very quickly and we've seen major
advances in in a couple of the verticals
the challenge of course with AI is it's
a very big broad mission in its purest
form we get to things like Ben Gert
CIL's formulation of artificial general
intelligence where we do see really
powerful successes recently or in areas
like reinforcement learning which has
historically been quite challenging but
is now starting to come online in in
real products and systems and we have
some interesting open source projects in
that area similarly computer vision is
in those several of those examples I
showed you we were able to actually
understand what's in a picture and be
able to take action on it whether that's
to protect for content violations or
something like that
abuse of the platform or also those
accessibility sorts of concerns also
natural language processing so this is
everything from machine translation to
also the examples like suicide detection
we have the ability to to address so
many individual utterances people are
making to others within their social
network that that our ability to
understand that and act upon it greatly
in a sort of rapid and intelligent way
is really powerful for us so we're
excited to see those sorts of advances
come online to do this at the scale of
billions of people around the world we
need to have a very capable way of
from research to production as I
mentioned at the beginning I'm actually
from Facebook's AI research group and so
we are a pure research organization us
doing open research with open datasets
publishing papers and using open code
and so we we do this very exploratory
fundamental research but then Facebook
is a larger entity also would like to
find ways to take research and bring it
into production and so that's really the
deep dive we're gonna do here is talk
about how we can make that journey using
specifically technology that has just
been built for PI George but I'm gonna
start at a conceptual level for anyone
in the room who's built systems in this
area before you you probably have
something like a mental model like this
in your head and you can see that you
have to go through all of these steps
when you're trying to model a problem
that is based on data and figure out how
to build a train your model and then
transfer it into production and that's
transfer into production thing it is
actually the challenge that I think is
is probably the hardest one for us to
think about how do we do this
effectively with and really design the
whole system to minimize the impact of
that because we when something is
successful we want to go all the way out
and deploy it and scale it to billions
of people so that's what we're focused
on specifically when the PI torch
project is to be able to minimize our
total time here by really doing is doing
a very different sort of design to your
whole AI platform to allow you to be
able to get to deploy and scale so much
faster in a way that there's just that
much smaller translation step out into
production mode and I'm gonna go into a
fair bit of detail about how we do that
so here's a sort of recent picture of
what it looks like to bring AI models
online at Facebook and so they have
different histories and they have sort
of different challenges I will show them
in a little bit more detail but here's
the rough path is that we typically do
research in PI torch export to a format
called onyx and then we use onyx to
import into our cafe to framework so if
you're not familiar with those stacks
I'm gonna explain them a little bit more
so PI torch in its classic mode
originated within fair as a tool for
Reece
who wanted a high degree of flexibility
and an extraordinary ease-of-use a very
pythonic user centric mode that feels
just like writing imperative eager
Python as people have been doing since
the existence of Python it's very
popular and its users love it
and it really opened up a lot of
possibilities for us to do exciting new
things fairly recently we created this
thing in collaboration with other others
in industry people like Microsoft and
Amazon this is the open neural network
exchange format if you don't work a lot
with in deep learning you may not have
come across this this is personally one
of the most exciting innovations in our
entire field from my personal view I
wrote a book called machine learning
systems and in it you can see a fair bit
of discussion around the challenges of
how is it that we serialize and
importing models how do we actually say
save our work and reuse it and do all
the things that we want to do around
that this is probably the biggest step
forward we have made in an industry in
terms of actually coming up with any
sort of reusable standard for machine
learning models of any form this is
really powerful I really love this and I
think this opens up a lot of
possibilities for us and it's I think
it's super important that we're doing
this in an open standards-based way that
anyone can participate in and lastly
that that last stuff I showed you in
that in our little flow of how a model
makes its way out to production within
the Facebook world is a framework called
cafe to Cafe - was developed at Facebook
for explicit targeting on for an
explicit intention to be used at this
scale of billions of users specifically
it performs 300 trillion
inference predictions per day that's
what we're doing with it already and so
this is something that is extremely
battle-hardened across servers and
mobile devices and it gives us the
ability to have a very strong story
about what it means to be ready for
production all right so this is a
workflow that we've done historically
I'm now going to talk about really the
latest and the greatest which we like to
call pi torch 1.0 because we've used
these modes where we prototype and then
we perform this transfer step and then
we deploy it out
but there's all sorts of ways in which
we want to make this a seamless
low-friction process because
historically while all of these
technologies work and have great
properties the fact is that they take
time and that there are there are
difficulties in getting things all the
way from research out to production the
sort of concept of what a high torch
classic model might be can be quite
different than what a static graph-based
framework like Cafe two thinks it might
be so what have we done about that we
focused on building a new platform which
we call pi torch 1.0 that really is
designed to make this a very smooth
transition from prototyping out to
production so what is pi torch 1.0 i'm
gonna give you a kind of a broad view of
a full feature set for folks who are
unfamiliar with the platform and then
I'm gonna dive a little bit deeper into
some of these specific stuff that you
might want to take advantage of in
taking a model from research to
production in that full path at its
highest level this is meant to be a
seamless path to production for AI it's
an open and accessible platform that is
usable by everyone around the world and
obviously we've thought a lot about how
you want to have a tool that makes this
transition some of the things we talked
about are that it should be fully loaded
that everything should be available in
there for you but every little feature
should be very opt-in so this is not
monolithic this is meant to adapt to the
problems that you have and so to allow
you to use the components that are most
suited to the challenges you're facing
all right so what are some of the things
you want out of an AIA
platform what what what are you actually
looking for when you're you're searching
around for something to solve for this
view one of them is hardware efficiency
and so in a lot of production AI use
cases we have really tight latency
constraints we need to turnaround
responses within milliseconds this also
gets in the issue of whether or not we
can afford to run these things at a
sufficient scale and so hardware
efficiency is is a major need and often
I think it's it's better within a
frameworks concern rather than within an
application level concern that gets into
scalability and so depending on what
you're doing there can be some really
hard challenges for folks who have been
working on
machine learning for you know five years
ten years more you remember how hard it
used to be to do things like distributed
training and for that matter
multi-threaded model serving there's a
lot of difficult engineering work in
there and it's great to have it out of
the box and and work sort of uniformly
the last is it needs to be
cross-platform we build applications
that that run on servers and on mobile
devices and the world of hardware
heterogeneity as we can move into a
world of things like AR and VR platforms
we only need yet more capabilities to
have the same functionality work across
a broad range of platforms and that gets
into things like we might need to remove
Python from our stack in places so when
we we built this platform we we had the
advantage that we're not starting from
scratch we had these two very successful
tool chains already you didn't use with
our system and so what we simply did was
we we merge them and we're calling that
PI torch 1.0 so let's talk about some of
those things in there so some of the
things that are really exciting about PI
torch 1.0 is that it's extraordinarily
fast in comparison to sort of pi torch
classic mode and so we get to take
advantage of some of the best in class
libraries from from people like Intel
and NVIDIA and so those are things like
kudiye NAND and mkl DNN and we're
continuing to improve this by adding yet
more high performance operators and see
these are the fundamental building
blocks of what allow us to be fast in a
production scale next is onyx is a
first-class citizen within pi towards
1.0 and why that matters to you is that
onyx is a rallying point for a lot of
development across across the ecosystem
so this is both at the software level
and at the hardware level allowing you
to do a lot of different things with an
onyx model it becomes very portable
across different tool chains and
different technologies you might want to
take advantage of all right as I
mentioned before distributed training
really hard so real world deep learning
applications today we're talking about
clusters of GPU enabled servers
this code is non-trivial getting really
good performance out of very expensive
hardware is a moving target and it's an
it's a significant challenge and so
we've invested a lot here and we still
maintain a high degree of flexibility
and so we have our new C 10 D
distributed training library and it
itself has gives you the option of three
pluggable backends which is really
designed to adapt to the specific needs
of the architectures of the models that
you're trying to serve I mentioned this
before this might sound strange from
someone telling you that you should
really use a thing called PI torch one
of the key features of PI torch is being
able to get away from Python and so I'm
gonna show this in a fair bit of detail
but the short version of what we're
talking about here is for all sorts of
deployment environments you may not have
the option of using Python this is
things like mobile devices as you look
into the future this could also probably
mean things like robotics what we want
to be able to do is be able to give you
a highly efficient executable runtime
for production that that is as efficient
as we can produce it and so we've
produced technology that allows you to
do that and I'll show you that as we get
into our compilation strategies this one
is a slide I had to update just
yesterday because we've in the original
version this slide I said oh this is
coming in the future it was just
released yesterday so there's there's a
couple of technologies we've released
out here FB GM and QM pack they're they
serve the same sort of purpose one is
focused on mobile one is focused on
server-side inference and this is an
important but subtle detail we use the
technique of quantization to get
extraordinary performance gains in using
deep learning models and so this is
using the right level of precision for
your application both for runtime and
performance but also for impact on
energy usage which can be really
important for things like battery life
on mobile or things like servers spend
if you're operating it at large scale
and as I mentioned mobile deployments
not easy if you've ever had to work on
it there's this huge array of different
chipsets and GPU accelerators we
still have different frameworks that we
need to address a lower level these are
things which often don't really interest
a person building a new machine learning
application particularly they want to
deploy it to both Android and iOS we
deal with a lot of this inside the
framework to allow you to be able to to
deal with the constraints and a
heterogeneity of the current mobile
landscape and so what we can you offer
today is the sort of battle-tested
approach of cafe to go where we're also
you also have the ability to use onyx to
export to different tools so there's the
ability to do things like convert onyx
into core ml for use on iOS devices and
we're going to continue to improve this
so that you get a yet more seamless
export to mobile from PI torch with the
least amount of work on your behalf I
want to give you a quick picture of
where we are in time so at PI torch Def
Con about a month ago we we sort of
announced our 1.0 Developer Preview and
we're shooting to launch the final
version of 1.0 by the nips conference
approximately next month and so you can
see that we have a lot of these new
features here that I showed and then by
future releases we're focusing on some
of those other improvements to
particularly export quantization and the
support for some of this stuff going on
a mobile so I want to talk about this
thing in some detail and so this is this
is a really exciting next step and this
is the torch get our just-in-time
compiler and this allows us to do some
pretty powerful things with models that
are expressed within Python but then get
compiled down into extremely efficient
representations and I'll walk you
through that in some detail and we
sometimes call this thing the hybrid
front-end and that'll become a little
bit clearer as we walk through what we
mean by eager and Static in graphs in
deep learning models we can see there a
definition of a normal program called an
eager program right so that we have we
have control flow there and so we need
to be able to rewrite that at times into
a static representation and so this is a
big difference in deep learning
frameworks historically pi torch being a
major leader within the mode of
of eager dynamic graphs and so we can
see that simple little rewrite here
I think this representation shows in our
C++ API and so you can see very minor
rewrites to things like if clause
allowing us to call down to control flow
representations that we can compile down
into a static form that allow us to do
things like give you extremely optimized
performance on hardware so the way that
we think about this right is that when
you're in eager mode which is still
available to you within Python or so
excuse me within pi torch you may want
to just be returning the result of your
neural network at a given point in time
or you may also want to be exporting the
graph what is the actual total data
structure of your program if we're
trying to make that transition to a
static mode the program itself only
produces the graph and then the graph
itself is the thing that produces the
result and so we have the ability to now
pass between these and I'm gonna show
you how that works briefly why do you
care about this though is that it's
great to have the flexibility of having
arbitrary control flow and having this
pythonic user centric mode of
interaction people like to do this it's
a great way to develop new technology
it's very hard to optimize and thus it's
very hard to deploy particularly when
you have real production constraints
whether they be on on something like a
mobile device or on a server
static graphs have the advantage of us
allowing us to be able to understand all
the work that's being done and thus we
can do a lot of things to optimize it
make it able to deploy but historically
we found that in the research mode the
static assumption really gets in the way
of the flexibility of designing of some
new things so we need to have ways to
work in both alright so as I mentioned
people really love this this way of
interacting with PI torch classic
interaction in this Iger imperative mode
because pi torch programs are just
Python they look like Python all the API
signatures look very similar to numb hi
this is a very natural way that we uses
a lot of people's existing knowledge
today we now think of this as I'm sorry
and again our challenge here is that we
actually have to use Python to run pure
Python
programs and thus we pay that
performance penalty we now call this
Python eager mode within pi torch we
that is to contrast with this the the
Python excuse me the PI torch script
mode so script mode is a new way of
thinking about taking your program and
incrementally evolving it so that
becomes more static in the ways that you
understand the state of what your
program needs to be and sort of making
that very smooth and simple transition
from research to production mode and so
I'm gonna show what that looks like
the key advantage here is that when we
finish this journey we're production
ready so here's a picture of our two
ways that we can take an eager mode PI
torch program and evolve it into a
static representation
those are scripting annotations and
tracing the point is once we actually
make the transition to the other side of
our diagram we're ready for production
we can take advantage of all those
capabilities I'm gonna walk through a
fairly step-by-step example of different
ways that you can take advantage of the
pike torch JIT to be able to
incrementally evolve your deep learning
program first one here is we're showing
how you can make a call to simply trace
this when we say trace what we're doing
is we're doing a single execution of
your program recording out all the
operations and then creating a static
representation of this this is really
useful if you have something like the
absence of control flow or a nice linear
computer vision model this is
appropriate for a lot of different
classes of models and the nice thing is
it's it's almost no code we just said
trace it with that trace model we can
now use it and to perform an inference
operation we can also take this in a bit
more of a step-by-step manner this shows
how to use the annotations and so we're
we're taking a module and we're going to
turn it into a script module and the one
little addition have to do is that
that's it and so by by saying that we
have a script method here we we say that
this is this part can be turned into
something static and so we're going to
then compile that down to a highly
efficient optimized representation this
is saving it out to a file pretty simple
stuff but now we have a representation
that can be used across runtimes
whether we whether we use the sort of
annotation approach or the tracing
approach this is has really nothing to
do with pi torch just here's a rough
skeleton of what a minimal C++
application is this is meant to stand in
for your model server your application
just to give you an idea of how you
would plug in a little bit of Pi torch
C++ code if your model server happened
to be a something like a multi-threaded
C++ application to be clear you don't
need to roll your own model server
depending on your application if you're
looking for things like server-side
inference we have great support and
relationships with Amazon Microsoft and
Google who have integrated first-class
PI touch support into all of their
relevant products and so this is ready
to go today you can just go click and
use it even in its 1.0 Developer Preview
Edition this is ready to go and so you
can use their model serving
functionality if that's appropriate for
what you're doing quick fYI there's a
little bit more to build a C++
application the code is in the docs
that's not as well then here because we
want to talk about once we are actually
using our models within production so
here this is just showing what it means
to actually then call that that
serialized optimized model from our C++
application it produced and so this is a
you know just to call out there to make
an inference operation we have to build
it because the C++ app and then when we
call it on our serialize model file we
get that prediction there you will
notice that the results here are exactly
identical to what we would get if we
used a PI torch eager mode with using
pure Python the difference here is of
course that we're getting vastly
superior performance depending on the
underlying hardware that we're able to
take advantage of when we compile for
that representation so that shows you a
full path going from your PI torch eager
mode model and incrementally evolving it
out to something that can be optimized
and deployed across highly efficient
server runtimes and on mobile ok so
here's a here's a quick overview of what
can we do today this is very much a
moving a moving target we're continuing
to add out new functionality to the PI
torch JIT this is a major area of
investment for us we really want to make
sure that what every year program wants
to express that there's a
way to to take those steps to
incrementally evolve it out to something
which can be sufficiently optimized on
things like GPUs and a mobile devices so
here's the snapshot as we see it right
now but we're continually releasing new
features and so the the docks and the
repo are obviously the best place to see
the latest and greatest but you can
already do a lot of it adaptation of
very real-world deep learning workloads
we we test this on both reference use
cases things like ResNet but also on our
own products and so this is this is
pretty powerful today to be able to get
enormous performance gains in that
transition from research to production I
really at the cost of a simple
annotation and as I said before you can
grab this right now the Developer
Preview is available on PI torch org we
already have tutorials and documentation
that show you how to use all of the new
features and this is moving fast and you
will continue to see new updates from us
in the future and so with that that is
all I have to present I want to thank
you very much your time and I can take a
couple questions but I'm also gonna do
office hours after this as well so if
you're developing models do you
recommend like starting off and that
kind of mmm you know I forgot the eager
mode first like ironing out your issues
and then going to the script mode is
that the kind of the workflow as
intended yeah absolutely that and and
there's a there's a benefit there that I
showed that is if you're doing every
stuff in that transition part of the
nice part of that is when someone is
doing pure research work very often
they're not the individual who would be
responsible for thinking about those
production concerns but you have a great
way of capturing their true intent in a
way that you can manipulate once you
start caring about those production
concerns and so someone else can also
just jump in there and start to play
around with that in a way that's that's
very non intrusive tracing ads
absolutely nothing and then in the case
of using annotations you're purely just
adding an annotation but then you start
to be able to tease out do we have what
we need for a production use case yes so
it's a microphone if you wanna use it or
I can repeat the question
hello good morning so how does exactly
the notation that converts the eager
function to describe work like how does
it and for that an if statement should
should be converted to a script if
statement right so the short answer is
it's complicated and so I mean from the
from the user perspective there's
absolutely nothing you need to care
about there but what we actually do is
were in each of those cases we're
finding a representation that allows us
to push it down to lower level of
operators very frequently what we're
concerned with is there a way that we
can translate this to an operator which
a GPU can understand so if you're
familiar with like CUDA operations or
something like that or do you actually
parse the ast of a function or the code
to do that so I don't actually run our
compiler team and so to a certain extent
the best person to answer your question
on to give you a detailed walkthrough of
how we perform that compilation but yes
we create an internal representation of
what is the program it's called the I
think PI torch IR is probably the most
legitimate name for that and so we're
able to translate that that
representation into something that we
can then compile down to efficient
operations which are themselves
comparatively more static avoiding the
need to perform like arbitrary Python
based control flow
[Music]